this let me show you or let me share you
a pipeline that we have set up for set
up in the server t bioinfo uh platform
pipeline is actually designed to compare
contrast and Benchmark different
clustering methods using gene expression
data so to give you a very short
overview about gene expression data we
all know that this data contains Vital
Information that is required to
understand the processes that takes
place in a biological organism in
relationship to its phenotypical
conditions or characteristics of
environment so to understand and
discovering these hidden patterns in
this gene expression data will help us
strengthen our understanding of the
complexity that is buried in the
biological networks and the complexity
the general complexity of the gene
expression data or omics data and the
volume of the genes present increases
our challenges of comprehending
interpreting and analyzing these huge
mass or volume of data so the use of
data mining techniques like clustering
is is one of the first few steps towards
addressing these challenges and we need
to do or we need to perform these
analysis methods to process several uh
the
patterns that are buried and interesting
patterns that are underlying in the data
so let's go back to the pipeline and I
want to bring to your notice to the
sequence of analysis that is involved in
this pipeline so we start with the
principle component analysis in our
library and and then we follow it up and
we take the output of the principal
component analysis and then apply a
multitude of clustering techniques like
hierarchical clustering like k-means
clustering spectral clustering DB scan
Etc and we finish the for we in the
pipeline so we do this to compare there
or these clustering methods
interpretation of the patterns within
the gene expression data that was
provided as an input so before running
to the output files let me tell you or
briefly show you what the input looks
like so if you check this input this is
an expression data and this data data
will look like
something like this as a table this is a
structured data that Elia had introduced
you to and this data is organized in
such a way that the samples are in the
columns and the genes are in the rows
usually this data will be of a huge
Dimension like the dimensions of the
gene can vary anywhere between
tens thousands to more even more like 27
thousands so if you check this one we
have curated this data and we have
around 7000 genes in this data even this
is a big data right so to understand the
patterns of this big data what we
actually do is we perform principle
component analysis before clustering so
what PCA does is PCA is actually used to
project this data of huge Dimensions
into a lower dimensional Subspace and
then the clustering is applied in this
Subspace so using PCA before clustering
actually logically reduces the diamond
reduces the
decreases or computational cost as we
are actually implementing clustering on
the reduced dimensions of the date
uh PCA will actually provide
distribution of the debt points in the
transform the dimensional space but PCA
itself will not cluster the data points
so to demonstrate you let's explore some
of the outputs that you find in the
pipeline once you run such pipeline you
will get some visualization options and
if you take some of the visualization
option
I think I have already loaded this
visualization so let's go there
yeah so you can explore the principle
component analysis output of this
pipeline in a 3D interactive plot so
this immediately shows us there is some
really good separation between the
samples of different types and if I can
move this over yeah and we have the
color coded
um Legend also available
so uh we quickly understand that there
is a variable uh or good separation
between the samples or at least between
the luminal and non-luminal type and we
can employ clustering to observe whether
these patterns are actually in the
clustering techniques or not or do we
have any do we see any other
surprising information in the clustering
so if you check another output which is
the tabular output of this principle
component analysis platform then we will
see that
the dimension which is of 7000 genes
that we have inputted have had been
compressed to three here we have given
only three it could be uh depending upon
the setting 3 5 10 or how many
components that you are going to
calculate right so uh thus a decrease or
using clustering on this decreased uh
dimensional space will actually speed up
your process and also will eliminate The
Unwanted noise which could be present
when you are dealing with the high
dimensional data so to understand all of
this pipeline we will have several of
these examples in this session or in the
in the program but now I want
to point you or focus on the bottleneck
of this pipeline which is the principal
component analysis on our input data so
if you click on the output files you
will get outputs that are associated
with all the analysis that we have run
we have actually used here included here
and if you include or if you download
this principle component analysis
underscore R Pac dot zip
and this actually contain the code that
was necessary for
the principal component analysis to
generate this output
so let's go there let's check it out
so this pack contains the input file as
we had downloaded and I showed it to you
and it contains the standard R code with
which we with which the server actually
ran uh this analysis so let's
yeah this is the r code which This
Server used to run this principle
component analysis of pipeline but we
have given or we have uh dissected this
R code in a step-by-step manner in an
Associated lesson which you get a free
chance or a chance to explore only for
today so if somebody can paste
uh
the link let me find the link myself
so this is a lesson that deals with the
principal component analysis of your
input data and I give you the link for
this lesson
in the chat box uh you are free to open
this lesson and explore the codes along
with me and you can we can walk through
the different components of the code and
we will have a we will have a separate
space where we are going to apply this
code and run this code from the learn
omics logic platform themselves
yes okay so in this lesson we we start
with an introduction to what principal
component analysis can do and how it is
very useful for us to uh first explore
the data using principal component
analysis uh as such and uh after you
have passed through that we give some
examples of the input methods or input
table then we we uh we discussed this
table now and we will also discuss this
table in Greater detail during the
program and in the learn the code
section this lesson is organized by
first giving you an introduction or a
specific aim for what this lesson is
intended to teach you or explain you and
then we straight away jump into learn
the code section where first you get a
demonstration of how to use PCA for your
data and then we have a code breakdown
so what do we call as code breakdown we
break down the codes into fundamental
components of the code and explain the
relevance of this code and explain how
it is or how different components of the
code and the syntax of the code come
together
and help you perform this analysis for
example we have to load some of the
libraries which will enable you to run
this analysis in for example in ours
environment so it is usually done by
including the library function and
followed by the name of the library and
then we definitely have to load our
input file and this is done by defining
where the file is or defining the
location of the file using the syntax
and this is the assignment operator in R
which will take the value of whatever is
on this side of the operator and then
assigns to the object that is on this
side of the operator
and then we load up the table or load up
the input file using a read.table
function and read.table function takes
at least one parameter and that one
parameter has to be the location from
where you can access the file right this
location can be your local computer or
this location can be a publicly
available uh
link that we usually share with uh with
uh with during these lessons and we have
to describe how our data looks like
right at least for for few of the
parameters we have to describe how our
data looks like if you check our input
file
[Music]
our input file contains if I can go
there
yes our input file contains the first
row which tells you what each and every
column is supposed to be so or in other
words in programming languages the first
row is the header of the columns right
we know that this column represents the
expression value of the sample that is
named by name this code and and so on so
forth and we need to mention that to R
so that the data is actually loaded uh
correctly so that becomes one of the
description of our input file and we
have several other descriptions like how
two columns are separated that will form
the separator that separates two columns
in our data this separator can be a tab
this separated can be comma or this
separator can be any special character
that you can use like semicolon like
pipe operator and Etc
and and you can also mention some
additional parameters like how you want
to treat the characters that is present
in your data table and whether or not
you want to load the First Column as the
row name which will be very useful for
further purposes right and then once you
have loaded the table into the object
full underscore table which in this case
and the read dot table function loads
this as a data frame so what is the data
frame you will learn much more about
data frame and Etc
in the sessions so uh in a nutshell data
frame is a collection of
data of different or various types a
metrics or an array is a collection of
data of specific data types but while
data frame can have data of different
data types like a character like The
Logical logical character like
categorical character and enumerator
character of course numerical inputs of
course so in order to run several of
this statistical analysis and several of
this analysis we may need to convert our
data frame into a matrix format so that
the numbers are interpreted properly so
we do that by converting and the only
those part of the data frame which
contains a numerical information and we
convert that into Matrix and we store
that into a matrix by the name
expression then we have to apply
principle component analysis along the
genes as Dimension so if you see or if
you notice our input data our input data
have the genes across rows so we need to
transpose the table and that's what this
specific
Code test and then we can now our
um
input file is ready and data file is
ready to be
analyzed for principle component
analysis and we can invoke or we can
call the application we can apply
principle component analysis in R by
calling the function PR cop and again we
are comp at its basic level takes at
least one input or one parameter that
has to be the Matrix uh that for which
the principal component analysis has to
be calculated and we mentioned that
Matrix and in addition to that you can
mention other options like how many
components you have to prep you have to
calculate
or you can mention other components like
uh do I have do we have to scale the
data do we have to Center the data
Etc and um once you run this analysis
then you can store the result of this
analysis in this object PCA and there
are several options in r that will
leverage the different organizations of
information that is present in this PCA
object so that we can plot we can
explore and we can understand the
principle component or analyzed
components of our input data so at the
basic level we can actually plot the
principal component analysis first two
components right pc1 and PC2 we can
simply plot it and we can understand
that it produces some good separation of
samples but this is just to see that
whether we have any outlier in our
sample or how do we go about
interpreting our data so this is very
basic plot which gives us very little
information like in for for example in
this case we see that there are no
alarming outliers in our data and there
is some sort of grouping that is
observed but without labeling these
groupings or without annotating these
samples we don't know what these where
these samples are what these samples
come from so that is what we can do in
the um in the following plots where we
explore different options or
exploring the range of this data
visualization options and parameters so
that you can label you can color and
increase the amount of information that
you can extract from this principle
component analysis pipeline or an output
so uh just like using plot we have
another way of interpreting the PCA
which takes GG fortifies library and
auto plot is that function and that
function comes with added advantage of
taking having some presets that are very
useful to us like it takes the
percentage of variance explained by
principle component one and principle
component two automatically without the
necessary of explicitly defining it and
it it produces some really nice
appealing graphics
and in addition to that what we can do
we can expand as I mentioned the to
other options or other parameters in
this autoplot function to include the
labels for the sample and we can color
the labels and we can color the uh
mention the size of the labels and that
will add one more layer of uh
information that we can uh that that
will help us understand the pattern now
we can see that how where individual
samples are actually located in our
principle component analysis this is
useful very useful if you have only a
handful number of samples even in this
case we have something around 40 or 52
samples and it becomes really difficult
to read some of them and to understand
what that sample means or what this
group means or what this specific sample
mean and where this where this uh what
are the characteristics or phenotypical
characteristics or different biological
conditions under which the measurement
from these samples are